hello everyone and welcome to another
gamespot news update I'm Peter Brown
microsoft announced earlier today that
it's finally releasing the Xbox one in
26 new countries including Japan and
much of Europe more details about the
availability of the console in these
regions will be available towards the
end of April Microsoft adds presumably
this will include pricing and specific
dates Microsoft corporate president
Yusuf Mehdi said you're spending an
average of over five hours per day on
Xbox one which seems like a weird thing
to say in an announcement aimed at 26
countries where the Xbox one is not
currently available midi added last week
we saw the highest number of hours lon
on xbox live since the launch of Xbox
one titanfall for a full list of
countries getting the Xbox one in the
near future go to gamespot com and check
out our list of the next 26 regions to
get Microsoft's latest console otherwise
stay tuned and games for all your gaming
news thanks for watching